of course we're all familiar with
emoticons or emojis as you kids love to
call him okay
that was an emoji for happy right there
you put it up again where it was
supposed to go there you go anyway I
thought it might be fun to make our own
emojis tonight on the show with the help
of Andy Richter who has a very
expressive face it's a little something
we're calling Andy the human emoji let's
try it out I'm ready okay we'll start
off with some easy ones but first let's
turn Andi into a human emoji go ahead
Andy do what you got to do a little
emoji stick stabiliser hear from Mike I
didn't know what that was it freaked me
out okay here we go
[Applause]
all right surprised Andy give us sad
about sad Andy oh now like our audience
member let's get really specific
give me an emoji for I think that's
Bradley Cooper at the next table all
right now do tell me more about your
fantasy football team all right next one
I totally understand how Bitcoin works I
can't get enough of these Girl Scout
cookies and finally I just stepped on a
lego barefoot
[Applause]
that's I have a terrible cold
you